now that we've linked atoms and bits
together we're able to tap all the
advantages that could be the innovation
and and organizational advantages of
bits with the attractions of physical
stuff that we can use in our regular
life so right now if you invent
something let's say for example in my
own company we do aerial robotics and so
we invent you know auto pilots and and
electronics for robotics
you know once upon a time you needed to
be a Sony to make sophisticated
electronics you need you know a factory
but now all we do is we just design it
with free tools we design these boards
on the computer much as you would design
a document and then we just click and
upload it and we upload it to two
companies anywhere there's some the
United States there's some in China and
they fabricate these boards for us a
couple bucks a board and a few days
later they show up by a FedEx at our
doorstop and now we're in the
electronics business we don't have
factories we are not caring very much
inventory didn't cost a lot of money and
we're able to because again these tools
of design and the factories of the world
are now willing to work with us as
individuals a long time ago they're like
you call him hello printed circuit board
Factory can you please take our order
and they're like who are you and we're
like we're nobody now if they have
websites so you can go to a site like
alibaba.com and just type you know say
you wanna you want to have a custom
electric motor just the right size the
right the right power type electric
motor you'll get a series of
manufacturers and there's hundreds of
them out there and increasing users say
okay well so here's the specs here's
exactly what I need I need a hundred
orders that maybe will start till with
ten as a sample and then their rights
then we'll order more credit card PayPal
you know the way you would shop on
Amazon is not so different the way then
from the way you learn how shopping for
custom manufacturing in China and so now
I have access to the exact same
factories tools manufacturing technology
the biggest companies of the world have
access to and I can order at a scale
that makes sense for me what happens
when you democratize the tools of
production is they need more people
produce and when more people were to
produce they make different things they
make things that the big companies might
not have made which it gives the long
tail of stuff my kids are really into
Lego
and we love Lego like I mixed tons of
stuff but there are things that Lego
doesn't make Lego doesn't make weapons
20th century weapons by and large
because they're family oriented company
but my kids want 20th century weapons
and not only do they want 20th century
weapons but my kids are also really into
Halo they really want Lego halo wells it
happens aleko hasn't licensed halo but
there's a market demand for Lego halo so
a guy named Will Chapman who's that
adult fan of Lego decided to just solve
that problem by making Master Chief so
today he has a company called brick arms
and you can buy weapons and there's also
a company called brick Forge and between
the two you can get Master Chief's
helmets his visor the assault rifle and
here's the nifty energy sword from the
Covenant all of it created by regular
folks using these powerful new tools all
those forces that we brought to
innovation and open source software we
can now do in hardware it's the same
thing people from around the world
regardless of where they come from can
come together to build something and by
clicking and and and typing they can
make physical stuff